as a doctor there have been many
experiences that encouraged me and
inspired me to write this book too often
in health care when we ask our patients
where do they want to die they tell us
at home surrounded by their families and
loved ones but the fact is most
Americans are still dying in our
hospitals often tethered to machines and
in a good deal of pain and suffering the
book addresses the conversation which is
that discussion that patients and
families and doctors need to have before
they become seriously ill there are many
reasons for that disconnect between
people saying they want to die at home
but ending up dying in our hospitals
first and foremost although we expect
our doctors to be master communicators
the fact is we don't really train them
on how to communicate to patients
look I finished medical school residency
and even became a young junior attending
and I had to show competency and how to
run a code how to perform CPR had to
perform a lumbar puncture but not a
single person actually certified that I
could actually talk to a patient and a
family about care at the end of life I
think that's a huge problem in our
health care system in our education
system that accounts for this disconnect
this misalignment between the type of
medical care patients want and the type
of medical care they end up getting in
our health care system today well I
think our there are a lot of things in
medicine that have led to this state of
affairs first is look we live in one of
the greatest places in the world where
science has conquered a lot when it
comes to disease and so I think the
expectation is the next new thing in
Health Sciences the next new cure we
live in a society that has a denial of
Aging and a denial of death I think
that's a large reason why doctors are
uncomfortable about talking about this
but also we as a society don't like to
talk about death and dying at all I
think a lot of people ask me what should
I as a non doctor know about you the
doctor when it comes to this topic and I
would say that look even though I'm a
doctor I struggle with this as well and
so I look forward to when my patient or
my family member tells me hey look I'd
like to talk about this it's an
important part of a good life
death as well and so I'm open to talking
to you about what's important to me if I
become seriously ill and in need of
medical care I think if more patients
started the conversation with their
doctors we'd have a much better
patient-doctor relationship I think
doctors need to know that it's okay to
broach this inherently difficult subject
matter